foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
until we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to have a look at HBO's official
new photos from this Sunday's episode
their official photos give us another
great look at what will happen now that
viserys is dead and the grains have the
Iron Throne as you can imagine runira
Damon and everyone on their side will
have to be smart about how they engage
their enemies moving forward now they
could Rush right into the city with
their dragons ablazing but that doesn't
always work out how you would think like
we saw at the end of Game of Thrones
they could end up losing everything they
were hoping to gain in order for raniera
to get the iron throne without losing
everything she loves I think she will
need to sharpen her mind and
intelligence and I know exactly how she
can get that done I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video brilliant now
for those of you who don't know
brilliant is a website and an app that
helps you learn different subjects like
math science and computer science
interactively which has been perfect for
me as a Hands-On learner brilliant is
the most convenient way to expand your
knowledge and challenge yourself on your
own time learn a little every day and
have a huge impact on your brain's
longevity I spend 30 minutes a day on
brilliant with my morning coffee rather
than on social media and it really gets
my mind ready for the day and I've
really learned to love challenging
myself to learn something new brilliant
has thousands of lessons with new
exclusive content added monthly there is
literally something for everybody you
can find everything on brilliant from
basic algebra and graphing all the way
up to college level content such as
neural networks and calculus you really
don't have to spend four years in a
fortune to master this stuff either now
since brilliant is interactive you will
manipulate simulations and answer
questions every step of the way if you
get stuck there's always helpful hints
and full explanations understanding stem
can help anyone level up I was able to
take the data science course and I
learned a lot that can help me evolve my
content for all of you now more than
ever the world needs more smart people
in understanding the science behind a
problem is always the first step in
solving it I strongly encourage you to
get on brilliant and challenge yourself
now to get started for free all you have
to do is visit brilliant.org talking
Thrones the first 200 of you to use my
link will get 20 off your annual premium
subscription once again I would like to
thank brilliant for sponsoring today's
video
all right now let's look at these new
official photos from HBO in this first
new photo we can see Alison is standing
beside her husband's dead body as we all
know viserys died in the last episode
after suffering from his illness for
well over a decade now that he's dead we
should see his daughter ranera Ascend
the Iron Throne since we all know he
made her his Heir however that's not
what's gonna happen in the new episode
since renero was back on Dragonstone
when this happens it gives Serato and
Allison A major advantage because they
want aegon sitting on the Iron Throne
next and so long as rhaenyra isn't there
and she's unaware of her father's demise
she won't be able to stop them from
sitting the crown on aegon's head we all
know Serato has always wanted aegon on
the iron throne but now Allison does as
well because she believes this is what
viserys wanted right before he died if
you remember in the last episode viserys
thought he was having a conversation
with his daughter ranera about aegon's
dream of A Song of Ice and Fire this is
something we have seen viserys and
ranera discuss all throughout this first
season Allison did not realize what
viserys actually meant in that moment
now she believes her son aegon is meant
for something much bigger than them so
she will also ensure he sits on the Iron
Throne before winero as soon as Serato
finds out viserys is gone he will have
King's Landing on lockdown he does not
want anyone finding out what happened so
he will make sure no Ravens are sent out
to the other great houses as well as
making sure all of the servants are
locked up in the cells under the red
keep it will ensure when era does not
find out about her father before they're
ready in HBO's official video they show
rainey's has been locked up inside of
the red key Serato will not only want
her silenced but he will want her
Allegiance as well we already know he
wants the valerion fleet on his side in
the last episode he was hoping he could
gain the Valerian Fleet by making an
alliance with vemon valerion but we all
know how that ended we also see a lot of
the servants getting locked up now they
won't be able to spread the word of what
happened in the castle in the official
video released by HBO we see some of the
Lord who were already in King's Landing
bending their knee before Serato who is
standing in front of the Iron Throne he
is making sure he has their allegiance
before he moves forward then we will see
him hold a small council meeting where
he will say the door will remain shut
until we finish our business Serato will
want the line of succession handled
immediately he obviously wants aegon on
the iron throne but there will be at
least one of the members on the small
Council who disagree with him in one of
HBO's other new photos we see Lord
beesberry shouting at the other members
he does not want to stand beside Serato
and Alison while they have aegon skip
over rhaenyra in the line of succession
his allegiance to renero will cost him
greatly as you can see in this scene
from HBO's video Lord beesberry is
already slumped over while sir Kristen
Cole faces off against sir Harold
westerling who happens to be his Lord
Commander it seems sir Harold westerling
does not want to stand with him either
sir Harold will leave their service and
this is how sir Kristen Cole will end up
becoming the new Lord Commander as we
all know he is now ride or die for
Alison Hightower now in the meantime
Serato and Alison will be searching for
aegon who was not in bed with his wife
when his father died this will force
Serato to have other men of the Kings
guard out looking for aegon in the
streets and back alleys of King's
Landing in the other new images we have
seen the brothers of the kingsguard Sir
Eric and Sir Ari Cargill dressed down in
rags while they're on the hunt for aegon
once again Serato will want this done in
secrecy which is why they're not wearing
their kingsguard armor it also seems
they will have aemond and Sir Kristen
Cole searching for aegon as well this
does look like aemon is discussing
something with sir Kristen Cohen the
photo now the reason why I think they're
also looking for aegon is because we see
aemon wearing the same hooded outfit as
the other kingsguard men while they're
out walking through the city in the new
photo HBO released we see aemon again in
the back alleys where the sex workers
are located we all know this is where
they will most likely find aegon since
we know he likes to sleep around with
various other women in fact he's having
so much fun it looks like he might even
be fathering Bastards of his own again
in HBO's official video we hear Lara
strong say I found out something you
should know while they show a small boy
who has the targaryen's famous silvery
white hair it would be very ironic if
aegon is out fathering bastards while
Alison is angry at Ranier for the same
thing we have already seen Allison give
one woman some Moon tea to help get rid
of any unwanted bastards so I would not
be shocked if aegon has had a son by
someone else eventually one of the
Cargill Brothers of the kingsguard will
find aegon we see him running after him
right here now once he's back inside the
red keep and he learns of his father's
death Allison and Serato will convince
him that he should take the iron throne
for himself it also seems they will be
holding his coronation in this Sunday's
episode not only did they show aegon the
conqueror's crown sitting on a small
green pillow I might add but they also
show all of the small faux heading for
the drag can pit in King's Landing if
you've read fire in blood then you know
this is where aegon's coronation will be
held unfortunately for rhaenyra her
father will have been dead for many many
days before she ever finds out and when
she eventually does it's already too
late the high Towers will have full
control over the city and many allies
while aegon is on the Iron Throne ready
to defend it with his life once again
this should make for one hell of an
interesting and exciting episode all
hell is about to break loose now that
viserys is no longer around to hold
everything together now his daughter and
his son will fight over the Iron Throne
until they nearly wipe out their whole
house I know I cannot wait to see how
everything comes to an end in this first
season let me know what all of you think
down below let me know if there's
anything I'm missing or overlooking as
always I want to thank all of you for
watching this video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]